does the um
scientific data that you've seen
suggest
that we need further restrictions and
further restrictions now
well i i mean in a word yes um we have
we're at risk and difficult moment
infections are rising fast uh we're
identifying more than 90 000 cases a day
now but that will translate actually
into hundreds of thousands of new cases
a day
and in london which is the worst
affected at the moment and incidentally
is also well not incidentally is also
the least well vaccinated part of the
country um hospital admissions are
rising significantly so
we need to act to hold down the rate of
hospital admissions um reduce the
pressure on the workforce and of course
a lot of people are off sick at the
moment and most importantly of all give
people the chance to get vaccinated to
get boosted and allow time for those
vaccinations to have effect
um let's unplug that in a moment but
before we do that
aside from the blue stone vaccination
what would you say
are the most effective steps uh policy
steps that could be taken
now
uh to slow the spread of omicron
the effective steps are the steps that
we can all take which have been the
steps all along which is that this is a
virus that transmits by uh moving from
one person to another particularly
through uh aerosol and droplet spread so
respiratory spread and so
uh distancing people one from another is
by far and away the most effective way
of stopping that spread but also wearing
clothes fitted masks
and
you know it's clear that people's
behavior is becoming more cautious um
and that makes common sense so it is
about as i say well fitting masks
avoiding crowded indoor poorly
ventilated spaces lots of people
reducing contacts and making sure that
we test a lot so we've got tests
and we should use the results if we have
symptoms we should isolate
these are all measures that we can take
um and plan b
you know is obviously heading in that
direction but the modeling projection
suggests that it won't be sufficient on
its own to
flatten the peak and reduce the pressure
on the health system
and on people being off work
do you support would you support chris
woody's advice
reduce the number of households that mix
try and avoid
essentially social contact social mixing
if you can over the next period
yes i mean what chris whittake said and
you know he is the nation's public
health doctor um and he's giving uh
excellent public health advice is that
you know reduce your contacts to those
that really matter to you so you know
the less the better but i mean this is
the second christmas that has the
potential to be significantly ruined for
a number of people
and so you know there are also the
health issues of not being able to see
your loved ones but so you know the
answer is to uh be prudent um and
you know only have the social contacts
which are really important to you
you've you've had the task of trying to
evaluate
significant
level amounts of scientific
data for government and advice ministers
and so on that is proving crucial right
now
there is a major issue about the
modeling uh that is that is emerging
from various sources um
i put to the health sector this morning
what uh the chair of the modern
committee of sage said which is that we
are generally asked to model uh we are
generally modeling what we are asked to
model
in a sense what he's saying is that
there is uh
the evidence that is being produced
is that which the politicians are asking
in order to support further restrictions
uh does that make sense to you that
actually what's happening here
it doesn't make any sense at all
actually um i mean the model is i mean
the first thing to do is say that the
modelers produce projections they don't
produce predictions
and all of the models have wide
uncertainties attached to them as well
and this has been no different
throughout this pandemic at all i mean
what the modelers are being asked to do
um is to
model what happens under various uh
conditions of you know free mixing less
mixing
um to provide the policy makers with the
best possible evidence they can have
there's no suggestion that you know the
evidence is there to support policy the
evidence is there to help policy makers
decide
and that's always been the case
and you know one of the big challenges
for everyone is that there is inevitably
a great deal of uncertainty particularly
during the early phases of a wave of you
know any pandemic infection and
particularly uh now where we've got the
omicron variant it's new we still don't
know a lot about it
um so you know frankly the evidence is
not there that it is either less severe
or more severe than the delta variant we
just don't know
but what we do know is that the cases
are rising very fast i mean anyone who
just looks at the numbers of cases can
see that
you can just look at the graph which is
widely available and you can see that
the numbers are going up extremely
rapidly
and
so that's that's what the modeling is
all about
so
but you do you do see what why this is
becoming a political issue that the
critics of the government are
essentially saying
that the evidence that is being demanded
is uh only evidence uh that will support
the their the government's desire to
impose greater restrictions and when
models are being different scenarios are
being offered as model as uh scientists
always do
you rightly say they're not predictions
they are different possibilities but the
the possibility on which ministers are
acting are the worst scenarios uh is
that
with respect a criticism that that you
can see the sense of
no the last thing any government wants
to do is to increase the restrictions i
mean
that that's
there's no political pressure of any
sort as it were to increase the
restrictions
it's all about actually responding to
the evidence from a pandemic where the
number of cases are rising fast we have
a new variant we have pressure on the
health service with increased hospital
admissions
uh the risks are that because of the lag
and that's always the challenge that
people you know forget each time that
from the moment you get an infection
become symptomatic to when you may have
to go into hospital is a week to ten
days or so and then it's another you
know two or three weeks before uh the
worst effects of the infection
particularly death may occur
and so you know if you're going to act
you actually have to act in advance and
that's one of the difficult things but
you know the job of the scientists is to
actually provide the evidence for the
policy makers the policy makers our
politicians and therefore ultimately the
decisions are political decisions but
there's no pressure on sage or sage
advisors or the modelers to do anything
other than provide the best possible
evidence you know given that there are
uncertainties at any moment
so mark thank you so much for your time
this morning much appreciated